[Musique]
la préservation de la planète est
aujourd'hui au cœur des préoccupations
un enjeu de taille pour le ministère des
armées premier propriétaire fonciers de
l'État et chargé de sécuriser le
deuxième espace maritime mondial avec
ces 200 000 militaires et des
équipements gourmands en carburant et
prodiguent en émission de CO2 la défense
détient l'empreinte environnementale la
plus importante de l'État mais depuis
plusieurs années les armées multiplient
les initiatives réduction du bilan
carbone développement des énergies
renouvelables protection de la
biodiversité tout en maintenant les
performances opérationnelles à un haut
niveau d'exigence
le journal de la défense vous propose de
découvrir comment les armées s'attachent
à devenir plus verte
du territoire national au théâtre
d'opération le ministère des armées
oeuvre pour une défense plus
respectueuse de l'environnement c'est le
cas notamment sur ces sites et terrain
militaires
le ministère des armées est concerné à
deux titres parce que c'est le plus gros
propriétaire foncier donc on a beaucoup
d'espaces naturels à protéger et deux
parce que la biodiversité sur nos
terrains est plus riche qu'ailleurs
parce qu'ils sont préservés des
activités de l'impact négatif des
activités humaines c'est à ce deux
titres là que la le ministère des armées
a décidé de mettre en place une
véritable stratégie de la biodiversité
ces terrains en grande partie utilisée
pour l'entraînement des forces ont
largement échappé à l'urbanisation et à
certains modes d'agriculture intensive
80% d'entre eux soient près de 200 000
hectares font aujourd'hui l'objet d'une
protection au titre de la biodiversité
c'est le cas du camp des Garrigues à
Nîmes dans le massif du Gardon ces 5000
hectares administrés par les
légionnaires du deuxième régiment
étranger d'infanterie représente ainsi
exceptionnel en matière de biodiversité
le site revêt une importance majeure
pour certaines espèces rares et menacées
d'oiseaux notamment
[Musique]
classés Natura 2000 le camp des
Garrigues a fait partie des quatre sites
avec le camp de Chambaran en Isère le
mont Côme dans le Var et la base navale
d'Aspretto encore choisi en France par
un projet life chargé de restaurer et
conserver la biodiversité sur les
terrains militaires
en jeu principal pour ces sites de
défense trouver le bon équilibre entre
contraintes opérationnelles et ambitions
environnementales
[Musique]
l'armée le deuxième riz connaît bien le
connaît bien la partie vraiment
personnelle mais beaucoup de zones
étaient gérées mal connu en matière de
richesse phonistique fleuristique et le
mystère des armées voulait se
réapproprier cette cette connaissance
afin de mieux réaliser leurs opérations
de mieux faire cohabiter l'aspect
opérationnel et l'aspect préservation de
l'environnement chacun s'est réapproprié
ces missions chacun s'est réapproprier
ces attributions et on s'est aperçu que
respecter l'environnement n'avait aucune
contrainte sur la préparation
opérationnelle bien au contraire on peut
dire après plusieurs années que ça a eu
un effet de levier favorable tant dans
pour l'acquisition l'obtention de moyens
dédiés à l'entretien la sécurisation des
installations et du camp
pour mener à bien ses objectifs de
préservation de la biodiversité le
ministère des armées développe depuis
2009 des partenariats avec les
principaux organismes experts comme la
Fédération des Conservatoires d'espaces
naturels l'Office National des Forêts et
la ligue de protection des oiseaux
le camp des Garrigues s'est rapproché en
2016 du syndicat mixte des Gorges du
Gardon qui a pour mission de préserver
et valoriser le territoire
depuis les rapaces comme le circaètes
sont surveillés des périmètres de
quiétude autour des aires de
reproduction sont respectées il en est
de même pour l'aide de bonnet lit qui
profite de la réintroduction du lapin de
garenne
logiquement quand on va réintroduire
donc je crois que c'est en fin d'année
là quand on va réintroduire quelques
lapins quelques lapins on va tout
refermer pour les acclimater ici
voilà 15 jours 3 semaines et après on
ouvre les trappes et comme ça après les
lapins peuvent sortir et aller vers le
coloniser vers l'extérieur
[Musique]
commence déjà à recoloniser d'accord
la Garenne a forcé à participer ça
marche ici il y en a deux ou trois
l'autre côté aussi sur l'autre Garenne
il y en a ça commence à venir à
s'étendre ça peut être le site
par les eaux de ruissellement deux ont
été financés par le programme LIFE et le
troisième par le fond d'intervention
pour l'environnement du ministère des
armées dès la première année dès
l'installation de lavogne on a une faune
au niveau des batraciens des amphibiens
on a des grenouilles on a tout tout un
réseau de libellules qui se met en place
les insectes aussi qui qui viennent à
coloniser ce milieu et qui engendre du
coup en effet de cycle de cycle de vie
avec les oiseaux qui mangent d'insectes
les prédateurs etc qui viennent
fréquenter ces lieux
en plus de préserver et pérenniser la
présence des fausses et fleurs locales
le camp des Garrigues s'attache à
réduire l'impact négatif de ses
activités sur l'environnement
le bivouac du materon est désormais
éco-responsable avec ces sanitaires à
lombricompostage également financé par
le fond d'intervention pour
l'environnement du ministère
[Musique]
son étoilettes autonome qui demande très
peu de maintenance qui se nettoient très
facilement car comme vous pouvez le voir
ici on est dans une zone naturelle où il
n'y a pas d'apport d'eau il n'y a pas
d'adduction d'eau il n'y a pas de réseau
d'assainissement donc elles doivent être
impérativement autonomes facile
d'entretien car les troubles de passage
et surtout robuste et pratique et donc
c'est le cas elles sont toujours en
permanence propre sur ce bivouac vert
des douches solaires facilement
transportables sont actuellement à
l'essai avant une éventuelle projection
sur les théâtres d'opération
en Bretagne le site maîtrise de
l'information de la Direction générale
de l'armement c'est aussi lancé dans une
démarche éco-responsable
depuis plus de 10 ans il met tout en
œuvre pour maîtriser l'impact de ses
activités sur l'environnement
un circuit biodiversité de 4 km
s'attache à valoriser la faune et la
flore locale et sensibiliser le
personnel à l'importance de ce
patrimoine
ce circuit permet effectivement de
découvrir nos jachères fleuris ensuite
il permet d'observer en fait les zones
naturelles humides que nous nous
attachons à conserver il permet aussi de
découvrir donc un élément important
c'est à dire notre zone naturelle en
fait d'intérêt écologique phonistique et
touristique en fait qui se caractérise
par des affleurements sistes rouges qui
sont vraiment très typiques en fait de
la zone où nous citons donc des pelouses
et des lents de sèches aussi sont
observés le long de ce chemin nous avons
aussi posé un certain nombre de nichoirs
à oiseaux des gîtes à chauve-souris
ainsi que des hôtels en fait pour les
abeilles sauvages et un hôtel géant
insectes ensuite sur ce parcours aussi
on peut découvrir en fait de nos bassins
de de nos eaux pluviales donc ces
bassins ont été plantés de roseaux
assurant ainsi un système de filtration
naturelle des eaux
le site encourage et développe
l'activité locale bretonne il fait appel
à l'écho pâturages pour entretenir
naturellement ses espaces déjà préservés
de longues dates de tout traitement
phytosanitaire le pâturage sur les sites
militaires c'est quelque chose
d'historique ça a toujours été en
relation avec les paysans nous on est
spécialisé en écopâturage plutôt urbain
périurbain avec une note précise c'est
le côté agricole donc nous on élève des
animaux sur ces sites là et on ne loue
pas les animaux on n'est pas là
simplement pour une problématique
d'entretien mais pour un relationnel
économie environnement agriculture le
site de la DGA nous a intéressé parce
qu'il correspondait à des réponses à des
problématiques qu'on avait en zone
urbaine on a énormément de
problématiques de vol et le site de la
DGA nous permettait de mettre à l'abri
une partie de notre troupeau et de le
faire reproduire sans avoir les
contraintes
extérieur et les vandalismes qui peut y
avoir auprès des animaux
et une problématique majeure pour ces
moutons avranchins
issus d'une race menacée d'extinction ça
nous semblait logique nous de prendre un
animal qui était adapté à son terroir et
à son territoire donc le choix de cette
race là était très important ça suppose
pour nous des problématiques de gestion
de la génétique de gestion d'un animal
qui du fait qu'il était en voie
d'extinction et qu'il l'est toujours
supposent énormément de de suivi
sanitaire et d'élevage mais c'est aussi
un défi et c'est aussi un investissement
vis-à-vis des structures militaires de
s'investir avec des race local et de
préserver un patrimoine local dans des
sites naturels qui sont très typés des
très différents d'un site à l'autre
ancrage agricole mais également apicole
cela fait 6 ans que Philippe charpentier
un ancien officier de la Direction
générale de l'armement à installer sur
le site serruche et leurs abeilles
sont très très riches justement parce
que c'est une nature qui est préservée
donc c'est pour cela que c'est vraiment
très intéressant pour les apiculteurs
devenir sur des sites comme cela on dit
souvent les abeilles les antennes bon
ici vous savez qu'on est sur le un site
donc il y a beaucoup d'antanes beaucoup
d'ondes de rayonnement
électromagnétiques mes abeilles ne sont
pas perturbés alors rien à la ruche dans
les villes d'ailleurs on fait un
excellent miel et les abeilles sont pas
perturbés pour autant donc ici donc ça
me permet de voir qu'il y a pas de souci
que mes abeilles retrouvent bien le
chemin de la ruche sur le site en tout
cas les initiatives sm
l'activité principale du site de est
l'activité numérique donc nous avons
décidé de regrouper en un seul lieu tous
nos bains informatiques
ces belles informatiques
dégage énormément de chaleur qui était
jusqu'à là perdu dans la nature donc
nous avons décidé de récupérer ces cette
chaleur pour pouvoir chauffer à terme
nos futurs bâtiments déjà émis on veut
être exemplaire en termes consommation
énergétique donc baisser notre empreinte
carbone et baisser tout ce qui est
émissions de gaz à effet de serre on
part aussi dans tout ce qui est une
augmentation de notre part d'énergie
renouvelable donc futur bâtiment
intégrera aussi des panneaux solaires et
on partira aussi sur une récupération
d'eau depuis aussi pour tout ce qui est
toilettes donc on essaie de rentabiliser
les éléments naturels de qu'on trouve en
Bretagne le soleil et la pluie
cette démarche tend à se généraliser
entre 2010 et 2018 la défense a réduit
ses consommations énergétiques hors
carburant opérationnel de plus de 15% et
diminuer ses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de plus de 18%
pour poursuivre et accélérer cet effort
Florence Parly ministre des armées a
souhaité la mise en place d'un groupe de
travail sur l'énergie objectif élaborer
une stratégie ministérielle d'ici le
mois de mars 2020
parmi les emprises qui se sont mises au
vert saint-christol-d'albion le deuxième
régiment étranger de génie est entré dès
2010 dans une transition énergétique
sans précédent se détournant des
énergies fossiles pour explorer les
opportunités du renouvelable on est ici
sur le plateau d'Albion un site avec une
biodiversité qui est incroyable et on
avait jusqu'en 2010 une chaudière qui
datait du temps du premier groupement
des missiles stratégiques qui étaient
vieillissante et qui émettait beaucoup
de gaz à effet de serre et qui était en
plus assez gourmande en énergie et donc
on avait une facture élevée et une
signature écologique mauvaise et la
prise de conscience de l'ensemble de la
défense du service infrastructure et
nous-mêmes finalement un permis de
d'avancer sur ce sujet pour améliorer
notre signature et de venir un camp
éco-responsable comme on est devenu
aujourd'hui
il y a déjà eu une première étape une
première démarche environnementale assez
forte dans les années 2010-2014 puisque
le SID a dans un premier temps changé
une chaufferie fuel pour une chaufferie
biomasse donc passer d'une énergie très
fossible et très initialement en gaz à
effet de serre a une énergie
renouvelable et il y a une deuxième
étape pour compléter la démarche
environnementale sur ce site qui s'est
conquête concrétisé en décembre 2016 par
la signature d'un contrat de performance
énergétique en fait il engage un
opérateur extérieur à venir sur le site
et à répondre à nos objectifs qui sont
de réduire nos consommations d'énergie
et d'augmenter le recours aux énergies
renouvelables sur le site
l'opérateur qu'on a sélectionné pour
venir travailler sur ce site à proposer
ce champ solaire thermique
ce système le plus important du genre en
France compte 160 miroirs réfléchissants
qui permettent de chauffer les bâtiments
du site en été l'alimentation du réseau
est 100% solaire le champ solaire il est
dimensionné pour en hiver vraiment venir
compléter la production de chauffage par
la chaufferie biomasse par une énergie
solaire et en été ce champ solaire il
produit de l'eau chaude qui va alimenter
les bâtiments du quartier en eau chaude
sanitaires et également qui va chauffer
l'eau de la piscine de manière intégrale
la piscine n'a pas d'autre système de
chauffage ces installations performantes
qui chauffent les 50 bâtiments du site
soit près de 90 000 m2 permettent une
réduction de 91% des émissions de CO2
chaque année
c'est pourquoi Florence Parly a choisi
Saint-Christol pour évoquer la
participation du ministère des armées au
plan gouvernemental place au soleil
une initiative qui vise à augmenter les
capacités de production d'électricité
d'origine solaire en France nous
mettrons donc à disposition d'ici la fin
de l'année 2022
2000 hectares de terrains pour y
développer des projets de production
d'électricité d'origine photovoltaïque
et le site de la Légion est directement
concerné le deuxième règle a en effet
été choisi pour accueillir une ferme
photovoltaïque de 5 hectares et demi
d'ici décembre 2019
autre point d'attention du ministère des
armées la question du carburant
le ministère des armées c'est en matière
de budgétaire la moitié du budget de
l'État c'est le ministère des armées et
dans cette moitié 70 à 80% c'est le
carburant opérationnel donc un enjeu et
une dépendance vis-à-vis des énergies
fossiles qui est très importante avec
une complexité derrière parce que
l'armée française n'agit pas seule elle
interagit avec d'autres armées donc on
peut pas avancer tout seul mais ça nous
empêche pas d'avoir mis en place au
niveau
opérationnel
à la fois des recherches sur les
systèmes d'armes donc on fait de
l'éco-conception en matière de système
d'armes d'une part et d'autre part des
recherches sur des carburants
alternatifs
ce qui se passait des carburants
fossiles sans binant envisageables pour
le moment le service des essences des
armées s’appelle à réduire son impact et
étudie des solutions plus propres
à Chalon-sur-Saône sur la base
pétrolière interarmée le groupement
école intègre depuis longtemps la
dimension environnementale dans la
formation des futurs soldats du pétrole
nos infrastructures disposent
d'équipements de sécurité qui évite le
rejet dans l'espace naturel de carburant
nos véhicules sont tous conformes à la
réglementation de transport de
marchandis dangereuses et nos soldats
les soldats du pétrole sont tous formés
au transport de marchandises dangereuses
nous sommes particulièrement vigilants
sur la qualité de nos conducteurs car
tous mettent en œuvre des camions
transportant des marchandises
dangereuses du carburant sur nos routes
mais également une opération extérieure
dans des terrains très accidentés et en
conditions opérationnelles
pour former ces conducteurs la base
pétrolière interarmée dispose de deux
simulateurs qui permettent aux
stagiaires d'acquérir une conduite plus
responsable
c'est-à-dire tous les jours on a une
façon de conduire et cette façon de
conduire on peut l'améliorer pour
consommer moins tous les jours et ici à
la BBA ça représente presque 700
personnes 700 conducteur potentiels qui
partent en mission après qui tous les
jours conduisent pour leur déplacement
quotidien et ces économies de carburant
bah c'est pour tous les jours tout le
temps et pour le bien de notre planète
finalement quand tu vas prendre ta
droite quand tu es arrivé au niveau des
cônes tu passeras ici tu sélectionneras
au-delà de la question du transport de
ces marchandises dangereuses la
consommation et la composition du
carburant font l'objet d'un temps
réflexion
à Marseille le centre d'expertise
pétrolière interarmée étudie des
solutions de carburant alternatif il
faut évoquer la veille technologique qui
a été mise en place par le service
notamment dans le domaine des carburants
on peut en particulier cité l'étude
menée sur les carburants alternatifs qui
a permis au Sea de publier une
spécification pour le carburateur qui
permet l'utilisation de composer
d'origine synthétiques pour les
aéronesses militaires de l'État
on constate une hybridation et une
électrification toujours plus poussée
des transports la question n'est plus
aujourd'hui de savoir si cela va se
produire ni avec quelle technologie mais
plutôt à quel échéance
dans ce cadre le pôle expertise du
service des essences des armées étudie
les technologies de stockage et de
production d'énergie
les forces armées prennent peu à peu la
mesure des impacts de leur activité
[Musique]
c'est notamment le cas de l'armée de
l'air avec son nouvel avion
d'instruction le Pilatus PC 21
pour le même temps de vol l'appareil
consomme près de deux fois moins que son
prédécesseur l'Alphajet
[Musique]
un autre domaine est au cœur des
préoccupations le traitement des déchets
ces déchets qui peuvent être sensibles
nécessitent une gestion particulière sur
terre mais aussi dans les eaux profondes
avec ces outre-mer c'est 7000 km de
littoral la France borde tous les océans
du monde avec une double mission assurer
la sécurité de ce milieu tout en le
préservant
on contribue au réseau des aires marines
protégées bien évidemment on a des zones
classées en Natura 2000 en mer
et puis on contribue de manière plus
proactive à la recherche ou à la
préservation des espèces en mer font
contribué à la préservation des
pollutions puisque notre marine arizon
les bateaux qui sont pris en flagrant
délit de pollution en mer d'une part et
d'autre part on protège les espèces
protégées la marine intervient également
contre la pêche illégale
pour limiter sa trace sur
l'environnement la Marine nationale
s'est engagée à adapter ses matériels et
procédures notamment sur la gestion des
déchets Hacket et en mer la protection
de l'environnement est prise très en
amont de nos processus quel que soit
l'activité que nous menons c'est un
analyse de risque vis-à-vis de la
protection de l'environnement c'est une
priorité tout le monde en est conscient
sur la base navale de Toulon et tout est
fait en sorte pour que il n'y ait pas
d'impact environnemental quoi qu'il soit
le plus faible possible en matière de
protection de l'environnement la base
navale de Toulon fait figure de
précurseurs il y a 10 ans l'opération de
nettoyage rate propre était initié
c'était d'abord une opération qui se
limitait au port militaire et puis
ensuite on l'a étendu aux villes de
Toulon La Seyne-sur-Mer et
Saint-Mandrier
pour lesquelles on a donc apporté notre
concours notamment pour la scène en
relevant des des épaves qui étaient sur
la corniche de tamaris avec la création
de la base de défense de Toulon en 2010
on a étendu cette opération à l'ensemble
des unités de la base de défense et
c'est devenu une opération importante
avec qui se déroule tous les ans depuis
10 ans donc
pendant la semaine du développement
durable et donc en 2019 on a eu un
résultat particulièrement important
parce qu'il y a plus de 750 personnes
qui ont participé 150 mètres cubes ont
été enlevés et on a relevé 20 épaves ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'au fur
mesure des années c'est vraiment venu
une oeuvre collective avec la
collectivité locale métropole Toulon
Provence Méditerranée et on sent
vraiment qu'avec un vecteur de cohésion
entre la les unités de la base de
défense et c'est de métropole dans le
avec l'objectif commun de sauvegarder
l'environnement et de protéger un
patrimoine qui est quand même
exceptionnel
les équipages des navires participent
aussi à cet engagement depuis 2011 le
label passeport propre vient d'ailleurs
récompenser les efforts réalisés en
matière de gestion des déchets
sur un navire de guerre c'est que à la
mer la réglementation est très stricte
comme un quai d'ailleurs mais plus
encore à la mer et
leur gestion des déchets est vraiment
très encadré et donc on s'est dit il y a
des bateaux qui font ça plutôt bien il y
en a qui le font peut-être un peu moins
bien et donc on va essayer de valoriser
ceux qui qui font des efforts dans ce
domaine donc voilà on a on a créé ce
label qui est vraiment une promotion des
équipages qui font des efforts dans le
domaine
parmi les bons élèves figurent le port
hélicoptère amphibie Dixmude
faire de lance du label passeport propre
parce que depuis qu'il a été qu'il ait
été mise en service il est quasiment
tous les ans labellisés par Sport propre
car il y a des filières de récupération
à l'intérieur du bâtiment ce qui est
assez rare et assez nouveau mais qui se
fait beaucoup sur les bâtiments modernes
[Musique]
déchets de type ménagers déchets de
cuisine ou déchets spéciaux pendant la
navigation tous sont triés stockés ou
traités en conséquence
en salle d'incinérateur le plastique le
papier et le carton sont broyés avant
d'être brûlés et les métaux légers sont
compactés
[Musique]
en cuisine le navire dispose d'un
broyeur pulpteur pour les restes
alimentaires
les déchets d'activité ou de soins à
risques infectieux générés par l'hôpital
du bord reçoit un traitement spécifique
deux machines de décontamination sont
présentes sur le bâtiment
si les équipages disposent de moyens à
bord et bénéficient des filières
françaises de gestion des déchets
hackais sur le théâtre d'opérations
extérieure terrestres la question est
tout autre
en France nous bénéficions de structure
adaptée pour le traitement des déchets
cependant dans les pays dans les pays
haute dans lesquels nous avons des
forces stationnées nous n'avons pas
forcément ces filières là à disposition
c'est une problématique qui est prise en
compte par les forces armées depuis un
moment et qui est important parce que
elle contribue en l'occurrence à la
bonne acceptabilité de la force et donc
de notre intégration dans le pays dans
lequel nous sommes cette gestion des
déchets n'a pas qu'une dimension
environnementale elle est aussi
stratégique ces stratégiques aussi parce
que tout déchet peut être aussi récupéré
et utiliser contre la force comme voilà
des bidons métalliques
réutilisées pour faire des IED donc pour
ça typiquement l'exemple on les écrase
de manière à ce que soit pas
réutilisable c'est aussi préserver
l'image de la France et enfin veillez à
ce qui est pas de contentieux avec le
pays qui nous aura accueilli lorsque la
force
phénomène climatique catastrophe
naturelle
dégradation des écosystèmes
les guerres de demain seront sans aucun
doute aggravées par les facteurs
climatiques
face à ces risques la construction d'une
défense durable qui protège et préserve
semble être aujourd'hui une nécessité
[Musique]